I have incredible economic data to start
today with and I tell you these jobs
numbers not because they are the proof
that everything Joe Biden has done has
been correct these numbers are not proof
that Biden has fixed the systemic and
structural issues with our economy which
include inequality and so many other
things which we talk about all the time
I give you these numbers so that you
understand that by the same metrics that
Republicans use to judge their
presidents the economy is doing fine now
fine doesn't mean there will never be a
recession fine doesn't mean some people
are unemployed fine means there is no
great alarm sounding of an imminent
Biden induced recession let's first talk
about the data 497
000 jobs added in June you might say
well I don't know
340 335 million people in the United
States is 497 000 new jobs in June
remarkable it's remarkable in the sense
that the estimate was that there would
only be 220 000 jobs added in June and
the real number 497
000 is more than double that more than
double that uh this is also
significantly more than the 267 000 jobs
that were added in May the leading
um uh industries were Leisure and
Hospitality some say Leisure I know
people who say Leisure and Hospitality
either way these are jobs paid in US
Dollars no matter what pronunciation you
use 232
000 of that 497 was Leisure and
hospitality
nearly a hundred thousand jobs in
construction trade transportation and
utilities at ninety thousand also
interesting when it comes to
construction this is an industry that
when you talk to to random people who
were supporters of Maga in uh Trump's
first term they would say construction
is booming under Trump and uh we really
think construction is an important
leading economic indicator when you see
more construction jobs you know that in
the future if it's commercial offices
that are being built those will
eventually be filled with tenants so
that's a leading indicator for a good
economy when you're talking about houses
single-family homes and condos when you
see construction jobs it means
single-family houses and condos are
being built and thus eventually when
those are those are built they will sell
and you will have people buying them
that these are leading indicators they
said under Trump we are seeing
construction uh jobs growing
significantly so what is the takeaway
here the takeaway is not one about we
now have a perfect economy we've solved
every problem we've ever had when it
comes to wages and employment and all of
these different things the point here is
that the right-wing media and
politicians are trying to spread a false
narrative
that narrative is that the Biden economy
is terrible and it's because of Joe
Biden and it is Joe Biden's policies
that have hurt the American people and
it's increasingly difficult to do this
we played a clip for you a few shows ago
of Larry Kudlow a former Trump economic
advisor appearing on Fox News and being
asked by the fox host listen the setup
was something like go check it out for
the exact wording but it was something
like we see all of these economic
indicators they look so good but explain
like why is the economy actually not so
good and Larry Kudlow was unable to do
so he said something about Ai and
Technology it was pathetic he failed to
make that case and so what Republicans
in the right have been relegated to is
cherry picking data ignoring context
distorting facts ignoring history to try
to undermine what is a very solid
economy
that happens to be taking place when Joe
Biden is President and is doing some
good things it's really important to
remember you know if you want shows that
play politics with this economic data
you can go and find them I don't know
which they are I certainly don't watch
them but you can go and find those shows
when we talk about economic data uh and
we talk about economies in general I try
to be crystal clear with you that most
of what we see is not directly related
to what the president does for example
inflation is coming down in just about
every Western wealthy industrialized
Nation whatever term you want to use
what we call the oecd countries
inflation has been coming down in all of
those uh countries so it's not because
of Biden that inflation is coming down
but inflation has been coming down
slightly faster in the United States
than in some of those other countries
and we can certainly point to some Biden
policies like the inflation reduction
act which are influencing that inflation
would be coming down anyway
but we can argue that the Biden policy
by Dynamics is helping that along
similarly
job creation we are seeing job creation
in many Western oecd countries but we
can say that what Joe Biden has done is
making that job creation a little more
robust than if we had for example Trump
policy in place it's also really
important to remember when we look at
the economy that economies don't
perfectly overlap in terms of their
movements with presidential terms it is
true that if you look back at the last
100 years or 120 years it is true that
we tend to see higher job creation when
there's a democrat in the white house we
tend to see better stock market
performance when a Democrat is in the
white house we see lower unemployment
when a Democrat is in the white house we
see lower inflation when a Democrat is
in the white house we see higher GDP
when a Democrat is in the White House
these are averages but it is not perfect
it is not perfectly aligned and so we
had Joe Biden coming in during the
covid-19 recovery
uh we had
um the American Rescue plan put in place
all of these different things and the
the timing of these economic movements
will not perfectly align for example we
started to see gas prices go up at the
end of Trump's term they continued going
up during Joe Biden then they started
coming down is one or the other
specifically to blame for those
movements no and so those are the types
of political games I try to avoid uh
playing with you the other thing is it's
important to look more broadly at some
of the other macro economic things that
are going on uh and again these are
going on globally the gloomy picture
that the right is trying to paint of the
American economy not only has to be done
by removing all context from the United
States economy but it also has to be
done by ignoring broadly what is
happening again in the western wealthy
industrialized oecd countries they are
all doing relatively well and that makes
it even harder to believe data aside
right if you nor the data that says
things are looking okay
it's harder to believe that things are
uniquely bad in the U.S when we see a
generally positive trend in most of
these Western economies so we're going
to continue following these numbers the
bottom line is this is not a terrible
economy it's a pretty good economy it's
interesting that Joe Biden has been able
to actually get done as much as he has
uh uh given the level of opposition that
Republicans have put forward and I would
actually go further the economy would
likely be even better were it not for
the obstruction of Republicans many of
whom voted against the things that Joe
Biden tried to do and has been able to
do but now want credit for them as we
talked about last week we need to teach
kids to think critically and
independently and we aren't doing a good
enough job of it I have a book right
here that teaches kids critical thinking
I wrote this book and it's available on
Amazon at davidpackman.com book this is
told through the story of a kid
detective the idea is critical thinking
thinking independently is like solving a
mystery getting clues evaluating them
thinking through scenarios the right
knows that when kids think critically
they don't end up being Republicans when
they're adults and that's why they hate
teaching kids critical thinking this
book alone won't solve the problem but
it will get kids interested get a copy
Kindle paperback davidpackman.com book